well welcome to CBS this morning on this
Friday we've got some big news this
morning we're going to begin with these
dramatic new developments in the
nationwide measles outbreak there are
hundreds of students and staff at two
major Southern California universities
that are under quarantined this morning
can you imagine if you were one of those
people
71 students a hundred and twenty-seven
staff members at California State
University Los Angeles who have been
exposed in a campus library are under
quarantine and at UCLA is 76 students
and six faculty members are still at
risk after a contagious student attended
classes corner Evans is at the UCLA
campus with the concern behind the
extraordinary precautions Carter good
morning good morning UCLA officials say
they've arranged for students to be
cared for here while quarantine but they
haven't responded to our questions as to
what exactly they're doing now this all
comes at a time when the government says
measles cases nationwide are increasing
dramatically officials at UCLA say a
student contagious with measles attended
classes for three days earlier this
month potentially putting hundreds at
risk it's crazy to see that that's
happening in a place that I like spend
time studying I think it's supposed to
be rotting in the university has
identified dozens who may have been
exposed they're being quarantined until
medical records can prove their immunity
you need to stay at a specified location
and you need to stay there until such
time that you are deemed as not likely
to come down with the disease that could
be anywhere from 24 hours to 7 days
earlier this month someone with measles
entered a library at Cal State LA health
officials have contacted some 200 staff
and students who work there they say
they have 2,000 visitors in that library
a day most of them don't sign in or out
so we've had a lot of exposure to folks
that we actually can't identify while
hundreds turned out for an anti vaccine
protest in the California Capitol
Wednesday the highly populous state has
managed to keep the number of measles
cases relatively under control due to
high vaccination rates with 38 cases so
far this year nationwide the government
has counted nearly 700 me
those cases roughly three-quarters of
them in new york state which had among
the largest and longest lasting
outbreaks since the disease was all but
eliminated in the year 2000 i have been
hyper aware of like all the symptoms and
stuff like i've been itchy and i'm like
do i have measles like I've been super
worried
now both UCLA and Cal State LA say the
building's effected no longer pose a
threat more than three-quarters of
California's measles patients were
either not vaccinated or did not receive
the recommended two doses of vaccine
Gail that is very scary stuff thank you
very much Carter